i know they're important but why do bats
have to be so
f and creepy all the time
oh boy um yeah they they ain't
creepy here's the thing you encounter
bats
at a time when you're feeling a sense of
foreboding and creepiness because
night is falling or something like that
and
when you get to know bats they really
aren't this way
for one thing you probably don't realize
that there are something like a thousand
species of bats
on earth that's a large number of
different kinds of creatures that's
almost a quarter of
mammal species and they are tremendously
diverse
some of them are even quite beautiful
quite easy to relate to you've probably
seen flying foxes from
the old world those are fruit bats and
flower bats from the old world that look
like dogs except hung upside down
yeah there's one can you put this on the
screen
yeah that's a terrapoted now this is a
non-echolocating
bat in a family it includes some very
large creatures
um but anyway bats i worked on
were new world fruit bats which are a
little strange looking is that could you
put up the picture i gave you
all right so here's some tent making
bats i took this picture
the last time heather and i were in the
amazon
um these guys are tiny little bats like
10 grams
a piece and you see they have fleshy
little appendages on their noses those
appendages do not have any bone in them
those appendages
when you hold one of these animals in
your hand the flat the nose leaf
jitters back and forth very uh
remarkably
if you watch bat mothers tend to their
offspring it's
absolutely adorable right they're very
they have tiny numbers of offspring
mothers will fly around with a bat
attached to them
under their wing and then when the
animal is
large enough that the mother can't fly
with it at the point that the
baby is more than 25 the size of the
mother they'll leave it in the roost
and they'll come back and they'll um
ferociously clean its wings of parasites
and things like this
and uh and feed the the offspring anyway
they really are in mammals a mother's
care for her baby is universal
it is universal even in centurio cynics
even oh you would bring up the i did
yeah
zack would you show centaurio the
wrinkle-faced bat uh you've got it
upside down
yes indeed um uh google returned it to
me upside down
oh really yeah surprising right it was
in the dark as it were
um so this animal uh this is another
phyllostomatic right
uh phylostomid yes it's a final stomach
bat
um fruit eater and this animal eats
fruits that it can't
carry so it kind of buries its face in a
large
fruit on the tree which is probably why
selection has
purged the face of fur
when this animal sleeps it pulls a
flap of skin over its face and that flap
of skin has two
light spots in it so it can see shadows
through it
um it's not a handsome creature no um
no it even hides from itself it even
hides from itself um
but anyway i guess my point would be
this in part two um i mean you started i
showed a picture of flying fox you
started by saying the flying foxes are
quite beautiful
um but no one living in the new world
ever sees those like they're not here
and
you know one of the misnomers is that
there's old world and new world bats
um and all the all the so-called old
world bats
are these beautiful flying foxes no
these these uh
these uh micro bats
these echo locators are actually the
vast majority of bats throughout the
world
and there are only a few of the megabats
um that are they're quite beautiful
actually but unless you're in
the old world which includes australia
and um
africa uh and some parts of south asia
you'll never run into them yeah and even
so you know what you might run into is
actually we did on one of our first
trips to madagascar
is um a tree full of them just beginning
to wake up at night and you might
effectively startle yourself so much
that you embarrass yourself in front of
the local people
as we did never happened never happened
um but anyway
the thing is you don't have good access
to bats in general so you don't realize
that all of the characteristics that
make a creature endearing
you know look you probably think rodents
are kind of creepy and gross
right but then you realize squirrels are
rodents and squirrels are actually
tremendously engaging highly intelligent
um fun to watch and i find bats are kind
of like this too there are some species
that are creepy i mean vampire bats
now that's a creepy animal and it smells
creepy but a
fishing bat is an amazing
animal that can basically detect the
presence of fish
when fish come up to the surface to feed
they make a ripple
this bat can detect the ripple with an
echolocation call
and it swoops in over the water and
gaffs the fish
this is an amazing remarkable thing and
it's not creepy it's fascinating
when you watch a fruit bet cleaning its
young it's endearing and so anyway i
think a lot of this has to do with the
fact that a
humans are sort of predisposed to be
creeped out by
things in the dark and b that our
encounter with bats is often
um at a distance and sort of the jarring
discovery that oh that's not a bird
um but that close encounters with these
things reveal
that they are um really
interesting mammals that
if flipped right side up and in the day
you would feel very differently about
them
[Music]